Thailand's former prime minister Jackson
shinawa has arrived after 13 years of
self-imposed Exile shinawa arrived
Justice type MPS prepared to vote for a
new prime minister the progressive move
forward won elections in May the party
leader Peta Lim jaronrat has been
prevented from taking office well Al
jazeera's Tony Chang is live for us at
the Bangkok International Airport Tony
why now and what do we make of this
timing
all right
it's a very interesting question we've
seen Mr Texan saying he wants to come
back for years then he picked up
activity on social media before the
election so I think there was an
assumption that his party per tie his
daughter was one of the Prime
ministerial candidates for that party
would win possibly even with a landslide
so he seemed very confident about the
facts that that he would be back soon
then they didn't they came in second
after the move forward party he said he
was still going to come back that was a
couple of weeks ago he delayed that we
assumed that some kind of a deal has
been made we know he wants to come back
he's 74 years old one of his great fears
is dying outside Thailand away from the
country of his birth and away from the
family that he clearly loves we don't
know whether some kind of a deal has
been done one of the things he did do
when he came out of the terminal here
was make a very deep bow on his knees to
of the royal portrait I think the
assumption is that some kind of a deal
has been done with the palace to
mitigate his sentence he's facing
potentially 10 years in jail for crimes
that were committed at trials that
occurred while he was outside the
country we think he'll probably serve a
token of that time he went back inside
out after coming out to Meet the Press
accompanied by the police we think
they're going to take him off to a
police station and then on to the
Supreme Court at some stage today but
all of that remains unresolved
nonetheless it is a hugely significant
event today Mr Texan has loomed large
overtired politics whether inside the
country or from overseas for the last
two decades this is a period of great
and stability in Thailand we still
haven't got a government after four
months after the election I think the
fact that Mr Texan is back here could
potentially further complicate matters
right and given the fact the fact that
Thai MPS prepare to vote for a new prime
minister today how could that complicate
things
well his party per Thai came out
yesterday saying they have pulled
together a coalition of parties that has
a significant voting Block in the lower
house in order to do that they've had to
bring in three of the parties they were
Allied to the military in the previous
administration that was something they
said they would never do if if that is
the case it would allow them to get
their Prime ministerial candidate
through but the big question is not in
the lower house it's in the upper house
where 250 Senators also had to vote and
they are all appointed by the military
that was what stopped Peter limberger
and rat the last time we tried to get a
PM a month ago his party moved forward
won the elections and yet they're still
not in power they're going to sit on the
sidelines as the opposition party this
time it's still unclear whether putai
can actually get through uh their their
candidate despite having the larger
Block in that building Coalition I think
many people waiting to see what happens
in Parliament later today uh the the
cabinets the Ministries how they're
allocated to all these different
Coalition Partners it's all going to get
very complicated I think for Thai voters
four months after the election one thing
they really want to see now is a
functioning government indeed what a
development Tony Chang live for us into
Bangkok International Airport thank you